joe biden qui accueillera justement le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky à
la maison blanche cet été annoncé cet
après midi du conseiller à la sécurité
nationale du président américain
ces derniers qui entament à partir de ce
mercredi une tournée en europe plus de
précision avec thomas bonnin en direct
de washington à thomas joe biden a
détaillé sa feuille de route dans une
tribune parue dans le washington post le
président américain a exposé sa volonté
de relancer les relations entre les
etats-unis et les pays européens
dans le détail thomas quelles sont les
ambitions de jubail man se il ya en tout
cas joe biden a donc détaillé dans cette
tribune le washington post sa feuille de
route et ce voyage doit marquer pour lui
une forme de renouveau après la
mandature de donald trump renouer les
liens avec les alliés européens et faire
front face aux menaces extérieures c'est
en tout cas comme ça qu'elles sont
présentées par joe biden joe biden qui
va donc arriver ce mercredi au royaume
uni va y rencontrer boris johnson le
premier ministre mais aussi la reine
d'angleterre
et puis se dérouleront les sommets du g7
et de l'otan et puis enfin le voyage de
joba y dénonçait s'achèvera à genève le
16 joueurs pour une rencontre avec
vladimir poutine est justement voici ce
à quoi il faut s'attendre pour cette
rencontre en tout cas selon les mots de
jeu baden dans cette fameuse tribune
écouté durant notre rencontre je vais à
nouveau souligné l'engagement des états
unis de l'europe et des démocraties
attaché au même principe pour défendre
la dignité et les droits humains nous
sommes unis pour répondre aux défis de
la russie envers la sécurité européenne
à commencer par son agression en ukraine
il n'y aura aucun doute sur la
résolution des états unis à défendre nos
valeurs démocratiques que nous ne
pouvons séparer nos intérêts parmi les
dossiers qui seront abordés lors de ces
différents sommets y aura l'ukraine
le président ukrainien qui semble
quelque peu irrité un par les dernières
décisions de la maison blanche
oui volodymyr zelensky regrette que le
président by donne ne s'oppose pas plus
fermement au projet de gazoduc north
stream ii une décision qu'il affirme
avoir découvert en lisant la presse
il faut dire que joe biden même s'il
sait trés mais s'est montré très
critique contre ce projet de gazoduc à
lever les sanctions imposées à
l'entreprise qui gère le projet une
façon pour lui d'envoyer un signal à
l'allemagne afin de relancer la
coopération entre les deux pays
ce à quoi répond zelensky combien de vie
chrétienne coûte la relation entre les
états unis et l'allemagne
vous aurez donc compris que cette
stratégie américaine ne plaît pas
beaucoup au président ukrainien qui dit
être passées de la colère à la déception
mais malgré tout zelensky dit garder une
part d'optimisme estimant que le
président américain tels maltais michael
jordan ce sont ses propres termes est
capable de laisser l'adversaire croire à
la victoire avant finalement d'empocher
la mise
et puis volodymyr zemlinsky regrettait
aussi de ne pas avoir eu la possibilité
de rencontrer le président américain
avant son déplacement en europe on a
donc appris cet après midi que les deux
présidents s'étaient eu au téléphone
qu'ils ont longuement échangé sur les
questions autour de la souveraineté de
l'ukraine et l'intégrité territoriale du
pays et puis on a donc appris aussi que
joe biden invité de manière officielle
le président ukrainien une visite ici à
washington à la maison blanche dans le
courant de l'été
merci thomas bonnet pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de washington est
on